[Music]  foreign  [Music]  thank you  it's very difficult yesterday we  extinguished one fire today another  people are dying and the worst thing is  that children are dying they haven't  lived their lives and they have already  seen this this is the worst  this is genocide of the ukrainian  population  that's what is happening now  senseless  and what was said  that they are aiming at the  infrastructure  and military forces  they're aiming at the civilians  and the evidence is just one of the many  buildings  that been destroyed  in cave  how would you describe the spirit of the  ukrainian people and your feeling about  this  the spirit right now everyone is angry i  talk to the people they don't want to  live  in this activity  bring much more  energy to everyone and everyone  understand don't want to live want to  defend defend our city  foreign